[Musica]
buonasera a tutti voi grazie per essere
qui
allora io sono venuta per raccontarvi i
retroscena di questa scoperta dell'acqua
liquida sotto la superficie di marte
esattamente sotto il polo sud marziano
solo che adesso michele via raccontato
tante belle storie sul fantasy e siccome
la scoperta dei retroscena quanto quasi
incredibili sarà molto difficile che io
adesso mi convinca che abbiamo trovato
l'acqua liquida sottomarca ci proverò ma
vedremo un pochettino allora potete
immaginare che ogni scoperta ha le sue
caratteristiche la scoperta che adesso
di cui vi parlerò è una scoperta
particolare perché innanzitutto ha
coinvolto tante persone alla fine noi
siamo stati in 22 pensate in tutta la
storia di dieci anni di sforzi che
abbiamo fatto per scoprire l'acqua sotto
marzo il contributo è stato di 22 22
persone quindi è stato un coacervo di
sensazioni di eventi di cose che sono
andate molto bene di cose che stavano
andando molto male molto male ma la cosa
più interessante è che dietro questa
scoperta c'è un fatto molto particolare
che quasi nessuno conosce e che io ho
intenzione di rivelarvi solo alla fine
della storia
quindi vi tengo adesso attaccati a
questa evento molto particolare e vi
racconto un pochettino come abbiamo
fatto e che cosa ci è successo in questi
dieci anni
bene partiamo con marte adesso qui
dietro di me vedete la superficie di
marte è la domanda che ci poniamo è
perché cerchiamo l'acqua l'acqua liquida
su marte
adesso se guardiamo questa bella
immagine questa è un'immagine di marzo
espresse il satellite che a bordo era
perché abbiamo utilizzato noi per gli
amici
max è da questa immagine vedete
chiaramente una cosa qui acqua non se ne
vede proprio questo è
tutto così asciutto più asciutto che non
si può marte se ci pensate se noi
prendessimo tutta l'acqua che è nella
piccola atmosfera di marzo e provassimo
a concentrarla verrebbe uno strato di
qualche micron e quindi vi rendete conto
che veramente un po come dicono gli
inglesi marte e bond rai cioè asciutto
come un osso bene ma perché ci cerchiamo
la qualità
la domanda è veramente una di quelle
domande formidabile che possiamo dire
della scienza e perché noi vogliamo
realmente capire se la terra è un unicum
nel sistema solare ovvero se la la vita
si è sviluppata solo sulla terra ossia
approvato quantomeno a svilupparsi sugli
altri pianeti
allora per capire qualcosa di questo
grossa grandissima domanda guardiamo un
attimo la terra bella terra
chiaramente è un oggetto molto molto
particolare la vedete in questa immagine
ne ho scelto questa perché dà un senso
proprio di dinamica ci sono tre uragani
che potete vedere alle mie spalle che si
stanno formando ma è open età dinamico
dentro quindi a un campo magnetico
perché ha un nucleo fluido all'interno
un nucleo solido interno un fluido e
stato dove ci sono delle correnti e
quindi crea un campo magnetico e questo
campo magnetico ci salva perché questo
campo magnetico crea uno schermo una
protezione rispetto alle particelle
cariche che ci arrivano dal sole il
famoso vento solare quindi questo fa sì
che si è potuta sviluppare un atmosfera
che la vita si è potuta sviluppare sulla
superficie
poi c'è acqua in abbondanza lo vedete
anzi le terre sono molto meno che non
l'estensione dei mari e quindi che cosa
possiamo dire possiamo dire che la terra
sicuramente con la sua dinamica è
sicuramente il posto dove doveva
svilupparsi la vita bene guardiamo la
terra in confronto altri pianeti e ne
guardiamo velocemente uno per uno
allora mercurio mercuri a un pianeta che
agli estremi molto molto freddo molto
molto caldo nessuno
l'atmosfera è oltretutto è quello più
vicino al sole quindi non avendo
l'atmosfera è bombardato da particelle
quindi è molto difficile che la vita
possa essersi sviluppata o comunque
possa possiamo trovare tracce di vita
vedere veder assomiglia molto alla terra
lo vedete è quasi scala le dimensioni
sono quelle ma venere ha un'atmosfera
terribile è come se voi avete aveste una
colonna d'acqua sulla testa di un
chilometro perché a 90 atmosfere alla
superficie la temperatura invivibile
oltre 400 gradi quindi un posto davvero
difficile in cui poter sviluppare la
vita marte marte già ci sembra un po più
interessante perché perché all'equatore
è una temperatura al di sopra dello zero
non simbolico e sono molto freddi
inoltre ha un po di atmosfera e circa un
centesimo dell'atmosfera terrestre ma un
po di atmosfera cela tant'è vero che se
vedete quando arrivano le sonde su marte
riescono atterrare usando i paracadute
quindi c'è un certo effetto di frena
mento ma marte che a noi sembra così
insolitamente desolato
in realtà ha avuto una storia passata
molto interessante lo vedete qui una
ricostruzione di quasi 4 miliardi di
anni fa parte un tempo aveva degli
oceani aveva dell'acqua acqua in
abbondanza di cui noi vediamo tracce
residue per esempio è tutta la
morfologia delle valli e dei laghi che
sono stati individuati attraverso varie
missioni spaziali quindi marte era un
tempo abbondante per l'acqua l'acqua in
parte c'è ancora perché se ne conservata
una parte sulle calotte polari ce n'è
una parte nel sottosuolo ma se uno fa un
bilancio idrico e prende tutta l'acqua
che un tempo c'era su marte quando marte
aveva un po più di atmosfera aveva un
piccolo campo magnetico che lo
proteggesse dal vento solare in queste
condizioni se facciamo due conti l'acqua
non torna cioè dovrebbe esserci più
acqua di quella che noi adesso
riusciamo a calcolare ea misurare con le
varie sonde quindi cerchiamo che cosa
cerchiamo di capire se c'è acqua sotto
il ghiaccio se c'è acqua nel sottosuolo
e se questa acqua e liquida vi dico
subito che l'acqua liquida sulla
superficie non ci può essere proprio
perché marte è una piccola atmosfera e
quindi qualsiasi goccia che uscisse
anche del terreno verrebbe aspirata
velocemente e portata via in atmosfera
a questo punto ecco il primo punto che
riguarda la scintilla
dobbiamo andare su marte dobbiamo
guardare se c'è acqua nel sottosuolo
come la facciamo questa misura cosa ci
inventiamo per fare una cosa di questo
genere
ritorniamo un attimo sulla terra
qualcuno di voi saprà che l'antartide è
un posto molto interessante come analogo
di marte per molti motivi
il motivo per noi più importante è il
fatto che l'antartide a acqua al di
sotto e noi lo sappiamo perché abbiamo
gli strumenti per guardarla noi sappiamo
guardare sotto quattro chilometri di
ghiaccio come facciamo facciamo un
ecografia al ghiaccio ma invece di
utilizzare onde acustiche come si fa con
un'ecografia usiamo onde radio onde
elettromagnetiche e le onde
elettromagnetiche a certe frequenze come
quelle del cellulare riescono a
penetrare anche in disturbi disturbate 4
km nel ghiaccio quindi da questa idea
che noi abbiamo sviluppato sulla terra
perché non portarlo a marte come
facciamo vi faccio vedere con questa
piccola animazione che cosa possiamo
fare
mandiamo un satellite questo volo a una
certa altezza anche a centinaia di
chilometri d'altezza
ma andiamo dei segnali radar i segnali
radar penetrano del sottosuolo penetrano
attraverso il piaccio e vengono riflessi
alla base del ghiaccio esattamente come
facciamo in antartide per studiare il
sottosuolo e ira di antartici dove c'è
acqua il segnale viene riflesso in
maniera molto
molto più forte molto molto più
brillante ricordatevi questo termine
dove c'è roccia il segnale è riflesso ma
non in maniera così brillante
detto questo altra scintilla giovanni
picardi professore di radar della
sapienza di roma ha un'idea molto
interessante insieme all'agenzia
spaziale italiana dice perché per la
prossima missione dell'esa che stavano
costruendo non costruiamo un radar che
guardi al di sotto di ghiaccio bene
questo radar è un oggetto enorme pensate
quando le antenne sono aperte sono
grandi quanto metà di un campo di calcio
quindi bisogna pensare a fare un radar
che neanche possiamo provare sulla terra
progettarlo costruirlo e mandarlo
intorno a marte per andare a cercare
l'acqua nel sottosuolo e questo è quello
che si fa con la lo sviluppo di martis
questo radar tutto a costruzione
italiana che viene montato lo vedete
alla mia sinistra in basso sul satellite
su next ok le antenne vengono pensate
ripiegate dentro delle scatole
un po come si fa con un metro da
falegname quindi è tutta ripiegata a
fisarmonica lo strumento parte arriva su
marte
lo vedete qui arriva il giorno di natale
del 2003 e poi l'anno dopo dovevamo
aprirla e queste antenne pensate queste
antenne devono essere aperte estese
passa un anno le antenne non si aprono
qui comincia il primo problema perché
perché gli ingegneri dell'esa hanno
paura che se fanno la manovra sbagliata
il satellite cominciare a ruotare su se
stesso ea di omissione considerate che
su questo satellite non c'è solo il
radar è italiano ma ci sono molti altri
strumenti che e credo che gli altri
scienziati sarebbero stati molto
arrabbiati quindi si aspetta addirittura
fino al 2005 per aprire
e altro brivido si comincia aprire
questa antenna un pezzo si apre rimane
metà aperta e non si riesce più aprile
ingegneri e ruotano il satellite verso
il sole ruotano i pannelli e riescono a
stendere finalmente questa antenna bene
fino adesso va tutto bene
questa è la prima immagine che sia del
sottosuolo di marte
e qui si vede benissimo che si vede un
po come il fondo dell'antartide in si
vede lo spessore del ghiaccio del polo
sud e la riflessione da sotto ma
giovanni non è contento giovanni picardi
dice no no io voglio i numeri voglio
concentrarmi in un punto del polo in cui
le riflessioni sono chiare noi possiamo
capire veramente che cosa c'è sotto
giustamente da buon ingegnere testardo
si mette la ricerca e cosa individua
individua lo vedete quel quadratino
quello lì è il polo sud di marte come a
studiarsi su una superficie questo
quadratino e dice noi dobbiamo acquisire
i dati qui perché la superficie liscia
non avremo problemi arriveremo nel sud
fino in fondo ai ghiacci
cominciamo a guardare e il 2008 e che
cosa scopriamo scopriamo una cosa
particolare in quella zona
noi cominciamo a vedere degli spot
brillanti in rada sta riflettendo dalla
base del ghiaccio qualcosa di anomalo
assolutamente anomalo ma i dati sono
poche quindi aspettiamo di acquisire
nuovi dati e passano gli anni
siamo nel 2008 arriviamo al 2010 al 2010
diciamo all'inizio del 2011 cominciamo a
dire va bene abbiamo molti dati e vi
faccio vedere che cosa abbiamo per voi
sono dischetti ma vi faccio notare una
cosa molto interessante io ho chiamato
questo qui il periodo dello scudo anti
smo perché perché i dati non tornano
vedete quei dischetti blu quei dischetti
blu ci dicono che è brillante ma sopra
ci sono quelli bianchi e quelli bianchi
ci dicono che non è brillata
quindi non abbiamo la ripetibilità della
misura è un momento di caos totale
cominciamo a discutere a cercare di
capire ma forse era a dar forse la sonda
che non funziona e pannelli non
funzionano
il cast completo all'interno del gruppo
di ricerca mentre noi discutiamo c'è la
scintilla di questo esperimento andrea
l'ingegnere che comanda la marx diceva
bene io faccio un operazione folle tolgo
tutto il processing al radar una cosa
che non si fa mai perché una volta che
il radar avete preparato lo avete
costruito avete creato un software che
funziona non potete cambiarlo perché se
qualcosa va male va male tutta la
missione e invece lui insiste e dice
bene io riprogramma il software di
martis tolgo tutto il processing e
andiamo a vedere che succede
e per fare questo utilizzo 4 memorie
extra che abbiamo dentro il radar
decidiamo di fare questa follia
convinciamo lesa e non è stata semplice
di riprogrammare il software che
facciamo acquisiamo di nuovo
ricominciamo da zero completamente da
zero acquisiamo per tre anni dati ok
e che cosa succede a un certo punto
succede quello che noi speravamo
guardate questa animazione queste sono
le orbite dei dati e riacquisiti dopo
tre anni
nel filmato si vede guardate il giallo
al centro se lo vedete ogni orbita che
passa in quel punto alla stesso tipo di
riflessione brillante questa volta le
misure sono ripetibili
i dati sono coerenti e possiamo
analizzarli
siamo alla fine del 2015 bene cosa
succede a questo punto questa è la
risposta che dobbiamo dare questa è
acqua o non è acqua
e qui subentra un altro problema quella
che io ho chiamato la paura della
scoperta noi abbiamo paura di dire che
acqua
cominciano a due anni di discussioni e
di modelli di calcoli per dire quella
non è acqua abbiamo passato due anni a
uccidere questa idea che potesse essere
l'acqua e non ci siamo assolutamente
riusciti alla fine questa è l'immagine
che otteniamo questa è l'immagine famosa
dell'articolo di science in cui si vede
perfettamente il lago questo lago viene
chiamato da noi argenta re un lagos
perché nel 2015 mentre noi lavoravamo
purtroppo picardi viene a mancare per
noi è una grossa mancanza ma credo che
gli dobbiamo moltissimo e l'argentario
siccome a lui piaceva andare a casa in
vacanza all'argentario a studiare
credo che sia il riconoscimento migliore
che possiamo fare
quindi dieci anni di stress pazzesco e
dieci anni di discussioni incredibili
dieci anni di ripensamenti totale di
momenti di difficoltà e di momenti di
ricominciare tutto daccapo ricominciare
dall'inizio
a questo punto però c'è un segreto in
tutto questo ed è una cosa incredibile e
io vi voglio raccontare vi ho portato
queste sono delle memorie pensate questo
radar è stato progettato negli anni 90
queste sono 8 mega di memoria
la cosa incredibile di tutto questo è
che queste memorie simili a queste più
un altro banco di memoria non dovevano
essere assolutamente dentro errata è
successo un certo punto che l'ingegnere
che stava costruendo scusate il radar
vede che c'è dello spazio nella scheda
chiama l'altro ingegnere e dice senti
qui c'è uno spazio perché non ci
mettiamo 16 mega di memoria vi rendete
conto 16 memoria non sono niente questi
sono 4 gb di memoria guardate le
dimensioni giusto per farvi capire
mettiamoci
l'altro ingegneri dice queste queste 16
mega di memoria ma io non ce l'ho beh
stiamo andando alla nasa
sentiamo che se loro ce l'hanno arrivano
al jpl alla nasa i colleghi della nasa
gli danno queste 16 mega di memoria loro
tornano in italia
ma cosa fa questo scienziato della nasa
le prende da un cassetto normali
normalissime ram non space quali fi no
le ram specifiche che dovevano andare
volare li mette in un sacchetto e
dall'ingegnere arrivano all'aeroporto a
milano i due ingegneri si devono
separare uno per roma uno va a milano
l'ingegnere che che va a roma alle le
memorie in tasca adesso una bustina di
plastica pensate alla memoria in tasca
passa la security siamo prima dell 11
settembre del 2001 passa la security
mette le mani in tasca dice porca
miseria le memorie in tasca le tira
fuori le lancia attraverso la security
all'altro incendiare che le prende al
volo le prende al volo le porta a torino
e le monta per queste quattro memorie
per questo incredibile colpo di fortuna
noi abbiamo scoperto l'acqua sotto 4 un
chilometro e mezzo di ghiaccio grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]